[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans mode
d'emploi votre émission consacrée à
l'emploi et à la formation
professionnelle la thématique de ce
numéro les travailleurs handicapés tout
de suite le sommaire de cette édition
rencontre avec geneviève croix et
chantepie en situation de handicap face
aux difficultés à trouver un emploi
elle se reconvertit et créé sa
micro-entreprise dans la santé et le
bien-être l'établissement santé et
service d'aidé par le travail de la
marsa 20 accueil 145 travailleurs
handicapés plusieurs activités
professionnelles adaptées aux handicaps
découverte de la structure
enfin retour sur la job academy handicap
organisée par face yvelines
au sein du site skf france de montigny
le bretonneux 13 travailleurs handicapés
accompagnés par treize collaborateurs de
l'entreprise et commençons ce magazine
par un témoignage geneviève croyais
chantepie a été reconnu travailleur
handicapé suite à cela elle a décidé de
créer son entreprise nous sommes allés à
la rencontre et les images sont signés
patrick jacques de dixmude
nous sommes avec geneviève croix et
chantepie bonjour mentionnons qu ils ont
dans votre espace bien-être puisque vous
êtes consultant de santé bien-être à
votre compte
oui alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer en quoi ça consiste alors moi
je m'occupe de la qualité de vie au
travail et du bien-être de la santé de
la prévention santé au travail
j'ai eu et j'ai encore un petit peu
d'activité auprès de particuliers
individuelle mais j'ai eu mon activité
aujourd'hui essentiellement centrée sur
les entreprises
qu'est-ce que en quoi ça consiste alors
en quoi ça consiste alors j'ai plusieurs
types d'interventions alors maintenant
je suis plus toute seule je travaille à
une équipe voilà et au sein des
entreprises nous proposerons des
massages des massages détente des
massages bien-être ce sont des massages
20 minutes de la relaxation des ateliers
collectifs les ateliers collectifs qui
sont sur des durées de 30,45 une heure
ou une heure voire une heure trente
voilà sur des thématiques prévention des
tms stress sommeil fatigue chronique
relaxation
je le répète je le rappelle vous êtes à
votre compte vous avez 58 ans et vous
exercer à votre compte depuis 2014
je le rappelle aussi vous êtes reconnu
comme travailleur handicapé vous avez
une déficience visuelle et vous pouvez
rapidement nous expliquer ce handicap
alors moi j'ai une déficience visuelle
j'ai pas de vision centrale donc en fait
une vision uniquement périphériques
c'est lire j'ai une acuité visuelle
aujourd'hui qui est en dessous de zéro
je ne peux pas lire je ne peux pas
écrire et je me déplace avec un visuel
de 2 ou 3 mètres en fonction de taches
claires foncé alors pourquoi vous êtes
lancés dans cette en auto-entreprenariat
dans cette aventure dans cette aventure
en fait cette aventure m'a un petit peu
choisit plus que je ne les choisis bon
voila moi j'ai j'ai été diagnostiquée
j'avais une quarantaine d'années pour
une maladie de la vue qui a qui s'est
dégradée au fil du temps sans que je me
rende compte donc jusqu'à jusqu'à 2011
j'avais encore une activité quasiment
normal je conduisais etc
et puis un moment donné voilà c'est la
pluie était possible je suis resté j'ai
eu un parcours de 6 années au chômage ou
diplômés
infirmière diplômée d'état un parcours
universitaire avec des diplômes
voilà mes cv ne recevaient absolument
aucune aucune réponse en fait quand je
m'étais pas handicap
on m'appelait dans les 30 minutes après
avoir posté une annonce il ya partie
moyen des handicaps j'avais absolument
aucune réponse
aujourd'hui les personnes en situation
de handicap visuel au niveau du chômage
on est à 47 % 1 1% pour les handicaps
lambda si je peux parler comme ça et 10%
pour la population normale donc le
handicap visuel fait particulièrement
peur
comment vous êtes se faire accompagner
parce que crée son entreprise ça va être
quelque chose de lourd ces démarches
alors il ya un gros parcours déjà de
projets professionnels de reconversion
professionnelle qui passe par la mdph et
la cramif pour un bilan de compétences
puis après il ya une recherche de
formation après il ya un parcours de
formation j'ai fait une année de
formation sur des techniques de massage
bien-être que j'ai poursuivi après avec
quatre ans autour de la médecine
chinoise et du shiatsu et puis du coup
on crée c'est facile et c'est en fait
c'est beaucoup basique du tout donc moi
je me suis fait accompagner pendant un
an par la bce 78 voilà vos perspectives
d'avenir parce que maintenant ça y est
vous vous y êtes
depuis 2014 ça fait cinq ans que
l'activité l'ansé à l'orme et
perspectives d'avenir je rejoins une
entité qui s'appelle alter massage c'est
une entreprise on est neuf on les neuf
salariés on est tous en situation de
handicap visuel
j'ai six collègues qui sont en voyant on
se déplace dans toute la france et ça a
permis de redimensionner complètement
mon activité ça a permis de me ça m'a
permis de récupérer des compétences
aujourd'hui je fais de la formation je
fais de la formation dédiée pour des
personnes en situation de handicap chez
la formation stress au travail
voilà ça m'a permis de récupérer une
multitude de compétences et de projets
qui ont été un moment donné arrêté dans
mon parcours et du coup c'est une belle
suite pour moi et c'est c'est le relais
idéal quoi j'avais le royaume champignon
merci beaucoup pour votre témoignage
merci beaucoup à vous
[Musique]
les établissements et services d aide
par le travail appelé aussi esat des
structures permettant aux personnes en
situation de handicap d'exercer une
activité professionnelle dans les
yvelines 21 sites accueillent près de
2000 personnes nous sommes allés dans
les actes située à trappes
regardez ce reportage à 25 ans crystal
goacolou est en poste à la blanchisserie
au sein de l'établissement et service
d'aidé par le travail de la marsa 22
trappe du lavage au séchage les
vêtements proviennent de plusieurs
clients comme les agents de la mairie de
trappes ce jour-là cristal est au
repassage le puits 2013 elle se
professionnalise sur ce métier j'ai fait
une validation des compétences sans
métier que j'aime bien et que
j'ai envie de
progresser comme faire un stage en
milieu ordinaire aussi de son côté
andreas luca 33 ans travaille au pôle
sous traitance
aujourd'hui il scotche des cadres sur
des photos vendues ensuite dans des
musées mais son projet professionnel
c'est l'informatique qui avait bien deux
tailles me tend la main
knowlton forme indique alors qu'1 que
veut évoluer dans le milieu de
l'informatique et de la maintenance
les aides de trappes accueil qu 145
travailleurs en situation de handicap
ils ont des postes adaptés dans quatre
pôles d'activité blanchisserie sous
traitance espaces verts et restauration
un accompagnement au quotidien par 40
professionnels dont 25 moniteurs
d'atelier l'objectif de notre
établissement c'est de contribuer à leur
pleine inclusion sociale comme n'importe
quel citoyen en ayant la possibilité de
travailler donc avoir une rémunération
et d'être autonome de ce point de vue là
est également un accompagnement
médico-social
le vendredi 27 septembre prochain les
adh de la marsa vin organise une journée
portes ouvertes l'occasion d'une
cérémonie de remise des médailles
d'honneur au travail pour 30
travailleurs de cet établissement
favoriser l'accès à l'emploi à travers
un système de parrainage c'est l'une des
activités de phase iib ville en
collaboration avec le groupe skf
implantée à montigny le bretonneux
le club d'entreprises yvelinois
organiser une job academy sur le
handicap
d'avril à juillet 2019 le principe
durant quatre mois
treize personnes reconnues travailleurs
handicapés accompagnés par treize
collaborateurs de skf l'heure est au
bilan nous sommes allés les rencontrer
sur le site de skf
regardez
nous sommes avec jérôme galichon
directeur juridique chez skf france
bonjour bonjour et vous étiez le parrain
de sylvie portal bonjour bonjour chanter
et du coup vous étiez en binôme pendant
trois mois
un binôme dans le cadre de la job
academy organisée avec face yvelines et
on va faire un bilan de cette expérience
mais avant cela je me tourne vers vous à
mes libertés
bonjour bonjour vous êtes chargé emploi
et développement rh chez skf france
déjà un premier mot sur la politique
autour du handicap chez skf france oui
alors on a deux choses déjà ça va être
de changer l'image que l'on a du
handicap en france et de renforcer
l'inclusion
donc en france
et après on a des actions qu'on a mis en
place des actions de recrutement on en
passe par des entreprises et des
organismes spécialisés et également la
mise en place de référents handicap
une des actions que vous avez menées
c'est le cas notamment avec face
yvelines que je le disais avec des
binômes donc treize personnes reconnues
travailleurs handicapés qui formaient un
binôme avec treize collaborateurs de skf
france sur le site de montigny le
bretonneux et c'est le cas de vous s'il
dit portal vous avez 58 ans vous êtes
travailleur handicapé en recherche
d'emploi alors quel bilan vous faites de
ceux de cette expérience de trois mois
c'était une expérience très original
déjà enrichissante surprenante aussi
déjà c'est par l'accueil de l'entreprise
skf moi j'ai été très touché par leur
volonté à s'investir auprès de nous au
travers des ateliers au travers de
l'accueil au travers du parrain voilà ce
que j'ai rencontré jérôme qui est une
belle personne mais qui m'a quand même
bien soutenu durant ces trois mois et on
à avancer pas à pas mais à chaque fois
on s'est vus il y avait un objectif qui
mon objectif à moi c'était de faire un
cv une page ce qui était quand même il
ya 58 ans que deux pages donc ça a été
un objectif réussi difficile voilà un
challenge
elle m'a fait confiance et elle m'a
raconté tout ce qu'elle a tout ce
qu'elles avaient vécu ce cas quelle
était la qualité son passé qu'elle était
sa vision de ce qu'elle voulait de ce
qu'elle voulait faire ensuite on en a
discuté et puis ensuite sont des étapes
petit à petit on chemine on chemine
ensemble est vraiment ensemble parce que
très gentiment civile vient de dire ce
que je lui apportez moi même apporté
plein de choses également
est-ce que c'est rester uniquement sur
le redonner confiance en soi en redonner
confiance en vos est-ce que vous avez
acquis des compétences que l'on peut
retrouver chez skf france
bah disons que des compétences qu'on
peut retrouver chez air france je sais
pas mais par rapport à ma recherche
d'emploi ou bas ça faisait 15 mois que
je travaillais plus puisque j'ai été
très malade et qu'il fallait que je m'y
remette
c'est vrai que d'être accompagné alors
que déjà on est avant en recherche
d'emploi et qu'après on tombe malade et
qu'après il faut aller rechercher du
travail alors qu'on n'est pas forcément
encore au top de sa forme
donc c'est vrai que ça donne à chaque
fois un but un objectif et et puis le
fait d'être dans l'entreprise je pense
en fait ça ça vous donne pas la même
vision
quand vous êtes accompagné moi j'ai déjà
été accompagné par pôle emploi enfin bon
c'est le jour et la nuit à ma liberté
finalement le but de cette initiative
c'était vraiment pas de recruter de
trouver de nouveaux collaborateurs
embauchés chez skf france mais c'était
plutôt remettre
disons le pied à l'étrier chez des
travailleurs comme sylvie qui n'avait
pas ce qu'ils avaient peut-être perdu
cette confiance qui avait peut-être
perdu cette envie oui tout à fait il y
avait cette sensibilisation de nos
collaborateurs au handicap et une fille
née aussi les filles alors les
développer l'estimé de soi leur dégoût
en entreprise aussi pour certaines
personnes qui qui n'avaient pas
travaillé depuis
de très longues années suivies portable
le mot de la fin avec vous quelles sont
les perspectives d'avenir pour vous là
bas j'ai un entretien jeudi retrouver du
travail dans mon secteur d'activité si
je peux et puis si éventuellement je
dois faire une reconversion
professionnelle j'ai déjà quelques
cartes en main et concrètement justement
dans quel domaine
on pourra vous retrouver je ne sais pas
encore éventuellement je vais penser à
la gestion de patrimoine alors que je
viens du véhicule device donc ces deux
choses très différentes
merci à tous les trois pour ce
témoignage ce retour sur cette
expérience chez skf france la job
academy en collaboration avec face
yvelines
8 % des 10 1841 demandeurs d'emploi sans
activité sur saint quentin en yvelines
ont le statut de travailleur handicapé à
la fin de l'année 2018 soit un peu plus
de 800 personnes
les démarches les conseils pour les
travailleurs handicapés en recherche
d'emploi on écoute marion massacre
conseillère pôle emploi à lagence de
guyancourt
regardez les dispositifs dead
l'accompagnement qui va avoir sur ba cap
emploi qui adore maintien dans l'emploi
les l'agefi qui peut subventionner des
aménagements ou des aides dans une
entreprise
après on a
des journées sensibilisation des
entreprises on a un forum recrutement
pendant la semaine du handicap et andy
recrutement avec l'américain signé
bretonneux et
et le cap emploi on a des journées
européennes sur le handicap duo dès
qu'on a fait cette année qui existe
depuis quatre ans et après on a au
niveau du bassin de saint quentin en
yvelines beaucoup d'associations
d'organismes de formation dédié aux
personnes handicapées aujourd'hui au
niveau des conseils on travaille
beaucoup sur la mise en avant des
comptes battante c'est vraiment ce qui
ce qui fait tout à un entretien
aujourd'hui ce qui fait que les
personnes sont recrutées
il faut qu'on sache dès le début s'il va
y avoir des accompagnements postes de
travail des aménagements si on le sait
pas ça risque d'être compliqué pour nous
est d'avoir des refus de la part des
entreprises parce qu'on n'était pas au
fait de tout la situation
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis vous pouvez revoir
cette émission en replay sur notre site
internet ou sur l'application mobile tv
78 à bientôt pour de nouvelles
découvertes et nouvelles opportunités
d'emploi sur tv 78
[Musique]